hello there guys and welcome to another
video so we've been given our first
official look at Indiana Jones 5 which
is releasing next year so you can see
the picture here and I gotta say seeing
this really hyped me up and just gave me
a rush of nostalgia because I'm a
massive Indian Jones fan so just seeing
him back in this outfit it was just
something really special so we have a
quote from Mr Ford and he says it's full
of Adventure full of laughs full of real
emotion and it's complex and it's Sneaky
the shooting of it was tough and long
but I'm very happy with the film that we
have I just thought it would be nice to
see one where Indiana Jones was at the
end of his journey and they were also
given a quote from the director James
Mangold it's become really important to
me to figure out how to make this movie
about a hero at Sunset the issues are
brought up about Indy's age were not
things I thought were being addressed in
the material being developed at the time
they were old jokes but the material
itself wasn't about it to me whatever
your greatest liability you shouldn't
fly towards that if you try to pretend
it's not there you end up getting slings
and arrows the whole way now it's
actually a really good sign that
Harrison Ford is actually excited about
this film he gets emotional about this
film when he speaks about it because you
know when he speaks about the Star Wars
films you know he's not too amped up
about that but for this film he's
actually seems to be really proud of it
and I think the director James mangled
is actually a really good choice because
he is the director of the Logan movie
which tackles an older character of
Wolverine Logan and that was handled
really really well so should we take the
philosophy of the director James man God
handling a character at an older age and
you know executing that really well that
gives me high hopes that this will
transfer well over to Indiana Jones and
they'll handle his character really well
and I hope he gets the send off that he
deserves because a mockinglayer was not
a fan of the Crystal Skull you know what
do you guys thought you guys excited for
this film let me know in the comment
section below